Best Supporting Actor winner Robin
Williams once said you're only given a
little spark of madness you must mustn't
lose it
tonight we celebrate that undeniable
spark of madness and the brilliance in
the performances by the following
nominees for Actor in a supporting role
Robert Duvall the judge ethan hawke
boyhood Edward Norton Birdman or the
unexpected virtue of ignorance
Mark Ruffalo Foxcatcher JK Simmons
whiplash
and the actor goes to the Oscar goes to
JK Simmons
you
Wow thank you thank you to the Academy
thank you to everyone involved in the
making of whiplash and I am grateful
every day for the most remarkable person
I know my wife the wonderful Michelle
Schumacher I'm grateful for your love
your kindness your wisdom your sacrifice
and your patience which brings me to the
above-average children even though I may
try the patient's more Joe and Olivia
you are extraordinary human beings smart
funny kind loving people and that's
because you are a reflection of your
mother and if I may call your mom
everybody I'm told it's like a billion
people or so call your mom call your dad
if you're lucky enough to have a parent
or two alive on this planet call them
don't text don't email call them on the
phone tell them you love them and thank
them and listen to them for as long as
they want to talk to you thank you thank
you mom and dad